not shockingly much of the controversy
around vaccine requirements is
dramatically exaggerated by people
looking to get attention people looking
to fundraise people looking to fear
Monger people looking to play the victim
card most Americans support vaccine
requirements for workplaces classrooms
and sporting events period but just a
majority when I say most I mean a
majority now I don't say this because I
think that just because something is
popular it should be the law
I don't uh there was a point where a lot
of people thought gay marriage shouldn't
be legal that didn't mean that that's
what it should be
um you don't put everything to a vote
but I say this because there is not
nearly the controversy over vaccine
requirements that some want you to
believe there is so the numbers from a
new CNN poll uh overall for everyday
activities only 51 favor versus 49
oppose vaccine requirements that's a
very very small it's basically within
the margin of error 50 50. but when you
say what about vaccine requirements for
places of work 54 are in favor the other
46 percent are split between against and
being unsure 54 percent say
vaccines should be required for places
of work 55 percent say vaccines should
be required for in-person classes
55 say vaccines should be required for
sporting events or concerts
comparatively only 41 percent say
vaccines should be required for the
grocery store that's predictable that
that's uh that's not shocking to me also
every month that this poll is done
support for these vaccine requirements
goes up and I anticipate that the
numbers will be even higher in terms of
support for these vaccine requirements
in another month so this is not
overwhelming support it's not like after
Sandy Hook with universal background
checks 88 90 percent of the country said
we need Universal background checks we
still couldn't get it done by the way
but it's a slight majority whereas
right-wing media would have you believe
this is tyranny over which the entire
country is outraged that's just not the
case part of the reason why support
continues to increase for these
requirements is that the virus is
spreading and things are really really
bad in much of the country if everyone
were vaccinated it would effectively
reduce the total Public Health burden of
covid down to about the level of the flu
we don't have that the unvaccinated are
burdening the health care System to such
a degree that there's very little choice
left but for Joe Biden to try these
ideas this sort of spreading
anti-vaxxerism that has infected so many
is a virus of itself it's its own
infection and let's be honest when we
say more than half the country supports
most of these requirements it's mostly
Democrats a fair number of Independents
and a very small number of Republicans
Public Health has become partisan
science has become partisan you don't
like the science pretend that science is
just an opinion and come up with a
different one that's a real tragedy that
we're experiencing and unfortunately
although we're dealing with it to a far
greater degree degree than most other
countries it's actually starting to
infect some other countries as well and
we're going to talk more about that a
little bit later on in the program let
me know if you favor
vaccine requirements for work
concerts grocery stores you can find me
on Twitter at dpacman and let me know
your thoughts